This is a VLIW target market quiz solution. So,
the question was, what is VLIW best for, among
these three options? We already know that VLIW is
best for things where the compiler can figure the
program out. Adding many numbers together is a very
easy thing for the compiler to figure out. Typically,
we are talking about a small loop with very
well controlled dependencies, and so on. In contrast, figuring out
the best path in a maze typically involves a lot of
decisions, and then we will have to do a lot of
if-conversions and so on, so it's going to be relatively inefficient, because
a lot of the instructions that you do are going to be predicated
out. And then counting elements in a linked list is going to
have probably a lot of load instructions. Some of them will
miss, some of them are not. So our compilers scheduling will
be greatly effected by the cache misses and so on. So this
is probably the best scenario for a VLIW. Followed probably by something
like this and it's unlikely to do well on something like this.